as the u.s was completing its withdrawal
from afghanistan the security council
was voting on a resolution meant as a
message for the taliban that the world
is watching
one such commitment which the taliban
has made publicly and privately is that
those who wish to leave afghanistan will
be able to do so
today's resolution signals just how
seriously the security council takes
that commitment along with the
commitments to allow humanitarian aid to
flow and prevent terrorism
russia and china expressed concern that
afghanistan could again become a safe
haven for armed groups who could attack
other countries but they abstained from
the vote
perhaps if we'd had more time the result
of the vote would have been different at
the same time we can see in this an
attempt to shift the blame for the
failure the collapse after 20 years of
the presence of the united states and
their allies in the region onto the
taliban and all the countries in the
region that will have to deal with the
results of this
western powers had hoped for unanimous
support and even stronger wording but
said further action is possible in the
coming weeks including when the mandate
for the un assistance mission in
afghanistan comes up for renewal in
mid-september today's resolution is an
important step towards a unified
international response to the situation
in afghanistan
we will continue to build on this
to ensure the council holds the taliban
accountable on its commitments
what leverage does the security council
have over the taliban one possible tool
is the lifting of sanctions the taliban
wants existing ones removed council
members said they could impose even more
if the taliban doesn't follow through on
its promises
kristen salumi al jazeera the united
nations